one thing i've always wanted with like a
lot of like a lot of like the whole life
members
but it's about like how you guys see
yourselves
because you guys are technically virtual
idols right
i guess so huh yeah but do you see
yourself as an idol
you know when you when you like debuted
and you know get all get all these you
know simpson
donations and everything like how how do
you view yourself as like a public
figure
wow um to be honest i'm still trying to
figure it out
because it happened about a month ago
right right um i suppose
uh all that i can say is i actually um
before
all of this uh i when i was just doing
uh underground things
uh in the underworld rap scene i kind of
i kind of like stuck up my nose a bit
um at idols i suppose i had this
attitude of um
of oh there's this whole industry built
around
um built around like worshipping these
people that are supposed to be more than
human
right um when they're not
right and i was like yeah
and i really i really kind of stuck up
my nose like oh i'm i'm so much better
than them i'm no idol i'm
i'm not an idol rapper i'm i'm an
underground rapper and that kind of
thing
um but then after actually getting into
the industry and actually
no it was before it was before that i
guess i will give a small shout out i
suppose to
the the indie not necessarily individual
but one vtuber that kind of changed my
mind about idols is
she's she's really um under the radar i
think
her name is milky queen um and she's
she's like a rice themed
a rice themed youtuber she speaks fluent
english fluent
fluent fluent english and japanese oh
wow and
we kind of we kind of became we kind of
became friends and
she really changed my mind about idols
because she's so down to earth and
and kind and an incredible singer and
talented and
i saw that the activities that she was
doing and i went to her events where she
was doing like
what is the the gacha events um there
are big competitions that youtubers do
to get like sponsorships and that kind
of stuff
and gosh wait wait wait wait wait wait
gotcha event they're called it's called
gotcha right what what are those about i
can't tell
you sure
let's go back to the gotcha i think it's
a different meaning though it's
different than that kind of gotcha
but you do events like compete for
sponsorships and there's this whole
other culture that i don't know anything
about but i saw him
it's like a tournament yeah kind of like
that but they stream
they stream and it's like whoever gets
whoever gets the most stuff thrown at
them in this application
i really need that first prize raised
shadow legend
right yeah that's fine i'm a
diamond-ranked gotcha player
i'll have you know and you'll have you
know my part is called a whale
no no it's i'm i'm a challenger here i'm
not a whale i'm a diamond league
yeah it was like she she competed
against a bunch of other
youtubers and they were competing for
like um to be the the image girl of a
restaurant or something
how would you compete um by streaming
and
you stream at the same time as some of
these other youtubers and it's like
whoever gets
i think the most stuff thrown at them
there's an application i probably
shouldn't even talk about or mention um
but there there's a place where they do
that
basically just it's just like a donation
wall exactly it's a donation
right it's a simp tournament guys
which by the way i will state uh hold
alive has nothing to do with this by the
way we
this is just something i know as me uh
feed the death god from what i've been
doing surely that was add more stress to
streaming
right right exactly it's already pretty
stressful adding that kind of these boys
are [ __ ] dying
well that was kind of my first exposure
to be honest to the whole youtuber thing
i didn't really understand it and i
watched her things right yeah um
and i guess suppose i suppose back
getting back to the idol thing right
um i kind of had these these ideas about
what idols were really like but
i realized watching her stuff she works
so hard and she's talented and kind and
humble
and other idols can be like that too
whoa no way no wonder so many people
like them and then i realized i was
being a jealous little hoe and now
so it's no problem
yeah exactly so ever since then i've had
no like problems or
weird feelings like that anymore i've
just kind of rode into the whole idol
thing like
with a lot of respect for my fellow
idols and all the hard work that they're
doing and my mind completely
changed which is something doesn't
happen often i mean you are an idol now
right
it would be kind of weird if i was
[ __ ] on myself right i suppose
i i'm curious because obviously as an
idol there's always a lot of like you
said worshipping going on
um do you is it i mean do you get a lot
of people
obviously trying to worship you to an
extent that's uncomfortable is that
something you ever have to deal with ah
well i feel like um
i feel like for for their for their sake
i try
my best not to get uncomfortable because
i know how that is to really really
admire
someone but you don't want to make them
uncomfortable right we've been there
before
definitely and i feel like people mostly
have like really good intentions i like
to believe that most people have good
intentions
you can tell when someone has the bad
intentions coming up to you right yes oh
for sure for sure
uh yeah obviously like you said as well
you were uh underground rap god before
is it frustrating when people try to
focus on what you were before
oh for sure yeah i get real sick of that
to be honest even sometimes when i'm
when i when i just i stop streaming and
i and i go down to the the underground
the underground cypher or whatever and
i'll go spit some bars
i still get some [ __ ] coming up to
me being like hey hey how's the youtuber
thing going on
and i'm just kind of like come on man
it's good thank you
it's good thank you thank you you know
and it's
it's kind of like i like what i'm doing
now and um
and i want things to just kind of stay
this way and um
and have those fond memories of the past
as well um and just kind of live
i don't mind living in those two
different ways i suppose yeah i mean i
mean
with me it sounds like you you'd like
trying to do a lot of different things
and um like you know doing this youtuber
thing is just another
path and like another skill that you're
trying trying out
right exactly are you are you enjoying
it as much as you thought you would or
did you did you even think about that
when you
you know wanted to become a youtuber in
the first place well to be honest when i
auditioned i
honestly didn't think that i was ever
going to get in at all so i never
thought that far
really um but hmm i don't really
i don't know if i can say if one way was
more fun than the other they're
different kinds of fun
right so it's kind of like that and um i
don't mind i don't mind those
those two existences being being
existences how do i say i'm bad at words
yeah
in case you couldn't tell uh the rapper
reaper is bad
at words but yeah i don't mind them
being parallel just don't be an [ __ ]
is all i'm going to say to you just
don't be an [ __ ] yeah you know i like
that be normal
you know you can enjoy you can enjoy
parallel don't be an awesome
exactly